In recent years the Mandeville community has
changed significantly with large growth in
small-block rural and residential areas.
In light of this, we are reviewing speed limits
in the area to make sure the community is
safe and speed limits are consistent and appropriate.
These roads are limited to 50km per hour
These roads are limited to 70km per hour
And these two stretches of road are limited
to 80km per hour.
All remaining roads currently have an open
road speed limit of 100km per hour.
There are three areas of interest that we
are focusing on in this review.
Should this section of Tram road have a lower
speed limit?
Should these lengths of Wards Road, Dawsons
Road and Bradleys Road have lower limits to
be consistent with McHughs Road and Mandeville
Road?
And should these cul-de-sacs and access roads
have lower speed limits to be consistent with
the Millfield Subdivision?
We’re holding drop in sessions on these
dates or you can find out more and give us
feedback at Waimakariri.govt.nz/Mandeville.